c'est un des thèmes du bureau de la
sécurité qui se déroule actuellement
nous la captation vidéo
il faut savoir que depuis quelques
années il n'y avait que les unités
spécialisées qui en étaient pourvus et
d'ailleurs les collègues au début était
un petit peu réfractaires à porter les
caméras piétons amenant les ont bien
changé d'avis puisque ce c'est une
réelle protection pour les policiers
sera le mérite de filmer toutes les
interventions tous les contrôles et
aussi le cas échéant toutes les
interpellations avec de l'image et aussi
du son parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
effectivement on l'a trop vu cela donc
notamment dans les médias
des séquences vidéo coupés de leur
contexte et où tout de suite mes
collègues ont été mis en difficulté
alors que l'intégralité de
l'intervention n'avait pas été filmée
donc au moins ce mérite de filmer
l'intégralité des interventions avec des
caméras piétons nouvelle génération qui
vont avoir une autonomie d'une autre me
d'une dizaine d'heures ce n'était pas le
cas avec celle qu'on avait à l'époque
puisqu'elle n'avait une autonomie de
batterie que deux heures non mais de
toute façon interne égal en masse et
d'acteurs au fait de disposer son image
chacun a droit de de conserver son image
alors l'autonomie est l'élu de 12 heures
c'est vrai qu effectivement les caméras
qui vivent 100 génération était très peu
utilisé un petit avellino de devenir à
l'imiter mais avec en fête ses trente
mille caméras petit temps on se dirige
tout droit vers une heure une
surveillance de vastes je vous rappelle
que le tage et l'officiel connu donc
répand les antécédents judiciaires
on revient déjà 8000 donc coteaux 1 et
que ce dispositif va permettre enfin de
compte de stocker en fait les images les
vidéos et en vue en fait le plan racial
ans dirigera vers 1 et on en
reconnaissance nation
[Musique]
l'objectif et nous de nous protéger trop
souvent et je vous le dit trop souvent
des collègues mes collègues ont été mis
en cause souvent injustement dans le
cadre d'interventions et à la lecture de
ces vidéos de ces contrôles de voir ce
qui se passe en amont pendant le
contrôle et le cas échéant pendant
l'interpellation nous pour nous c'est
une vraie sécurité et l'utilisation
massive de ces caméras ce n'est pas du
tout dans le cadre par exemple de
manifestation mais de de contrôle du
quotidien de lutte contre la délinquance
quotidienne
donc voilà j'ai pas le sentiment que
c'est une atteinte à la liberté
individuelle vous savez d'où les
policiers qu'on ne m'aime pas nous mêmes
propriétaires de notre image vous avez
droit de filmer un policier par contre
n'est pas le droit de l'utiliser saisie
majeure dans le but de 2008 mais nous ne
sommes pas inquiets les policiers a
vraiment changé d'avis par rapport à ça
il ya quelques années il était plutôt
réfractaire à ce genre d'utilisation de
matériels et aujourd'hui ne l'est plus
c'est qu'on a franchi un cap
l'élément comment ces images parce que
témoignages il est écrit les policiers
sont assermentés
donc il est très difficile nous pour
nous un vrai que lorsqu'on dit un
manifestant qui accusé à tort de mettre
en cause empêche le témoignage du
policier
voilà six rallyes lui si vous avez beau
avoir franck témoignage à l'encontre du
policier de manifestants par exemple aux
policiers étant assermentés si sa parole
qui prévaut matute relax j'ai pu obtenir
c'est par l'image par la vidéo et toutes
les condamnations policiers qui est
également un peu au kényan s'est
également par la bio donc ça la vidéo ça
à l'interné mais pour en revenir aux
caméras piétons après faut voir la
fiabilité de laquelle vient rappeler on
a connu ça dans lequel des violences
policières soient les bio ne
fonctionnait pas soit la vidéo n'était
pas complète donc je reste quand même
assez sceptique en fait sur
l'utilisation de ces caméras piétons
l'image leur n'a droit image fait partie
également du respect de notre vie privée
le stockage d'imagés fait être stocké un
certain temps puisque il pourra être à
disposition de la justice mais ensuite
ces vidéos seront évidemment détruites
au niveau la reconnaissance faciale
non on n'en parle pas et pour en ce qui
nous concerne nous c'est pas notre
priorité c'est pas à l'ordre du jour
vous savez je voulais te dire à monsieur
l'avocat c'est que nous aussi on tient
aussi à notre image c'est important il
vous a pas échappé que notre image et se
retrouve souvent sur des réseaux sociaux
se retrouvent souvent placardé sur web
des halls d'immeuble donc là aussi le
policier il faut pas oublier que c'est
un citoyen à part entière et je voudrais
le souligner aussi non mais enfin en
fait le principe de la reconnaissance
faciale c'est c'est sa généralisation
je veux dire on a le droit à une vie
privée je répète en a le droit de ne
porte pas atteinte à notre intégrité
viable et bien notre image donc la
reconnaissance faciale eu
malheureusement j'ai bien peur que ça va
être généralisé dans l'avenir la
difficulté si le stockage aussi deux de
ces images et de ses vidéos qui pose le
problème de l'âge d'un point de vue
juridique
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui vont
être filmés alors qu'ils n'ont pas
commis d'infraction parce que on sera
passé à des interventions policières
mais j'ai bien peur en fin de compte ça
va permettre l'entrée de la cité des
gens et de les surveiller